we've got the report is now in it's
called the matter referred on the 22nd
of April 2020 coordinator campaign of
interference in the work of the
privileged committee it names a number
of MPS Nadine dory's Jacob Reese smog
Andrew Jenkins uh uh and it says pretty
Patel Michael fabricant Mark uh
jenkinson and it says that this special
supplement reports puts on record our
concern at the improper pressure brought
to bear on the committee and its members
throughout this inquiry and it says that
the work of the privileged committee is
crucial to our democracy it must itself
be protected Brendan Clark Smith is all
Brandon Clark Smith is also named on it
as is Lord Zach Goldsmith so a number of
key Boris Johnson allies are
individually named and criticized and
we're just waiting to see what the
recommendations are they're just running
through the pages it's a 14 page report
yeah so just some of the names there
that we heard from bethash continues to
look through this report for us include
Jacob Reese Morgan Nadine Doris names
that we already expected but
interestingly pretty Patel
um her name in there as well and Zach
Goldsmith who uh recently I think I'm
writing saying was uh elevated if that's
the right word to the Lords and they
have haircut I'm just looking through it
now they have individual MPS and and as
you said Zach Goldsmith who's now a lord
they name them and then they have
remarks comments so with Nadine Doris
they say Twitter and they quote her
saying we also need to keep a close eye
on the careers of conservative MPS who
sat on that committee do they suddenly
find themselves on chicken runs into
safe seats or gongs with promises made
uh on Mark jenkinson on Twitter when the
Witch Hunt has hunt has been forgotten
future Generations will look back in
astonishment Brendan Clark Smith named
again Twitter here saying tonight we saw
the end result for parliamentary which
hunt would which would put a baranana
republic to shame it's the people of
this country who elect and decide their
MPS it's called democracy and we use it
to Value uh sorry someone just tried to
phone me and we use it uh use it to we
used to Value it here sadly this no
longer appears to be the case so they
are naming a number of MPS with the
evidence here's the recommendations we
recommend that the house agree a
resolution in the following terms that
this house notes with approval the
special report from the committee of
privileges and its weights to be seen
we're just having a look to see uh what
the sanctions might or might be the
report does say that the Privileges
committee needs explicit protection so
really this is the wash-up of a feeling
from those MPS that they were heavily
under attack for basically carrying out
as they saw it uh the wishes of
parliament this Reserve to that end Beth
let me just to highlight what's on air
at the moment and we're looking at
paragraph 15 if you're watching us at
home pressure was applied particularly
to conservative members of the committee
this had the clear intention to drive
those members off the committee and so
to frustrate the intention of the house
that the inquiry should be carried out
or to prevent the inquiry coming to a
conclusion which the critics did not
want there was also sustained attempts
to undermine and challenge the
impartiality of the chair Harriet Harman
who had been appointed to the committee
by unanimous decision of the house so
that's I mean that's a severe claim is
it that they were literally trying to
influence yeah and the committee and the
reason that matters is that if there's a
sense that you're trying to push
conservative members off you can't then
say it's a cross-party committee the
committee is made up reflects the
membership of the House Apartments
there's a majority of MPS of the seven
four of them were conservative MPS and
if you could push them off the committee
you could then claim that the committee
didn't stand it also says in the report
K that it's going to be for the house to
consider what further action if any to
take in respect of the members of the
House referred to in this special report
so we wait to see whether any further
action will be taken eight names in
total as I said Lord Goldsmith and then
a number of MPS so it quite critical of
uh these MPS this is paragraph 14. those
involve use newspapers and radio and
those extensive use of social media
there were many examples but the
committee is particularly concerned
about tax mounted by experienced
colleagues including a serving minister
of the crown a former leader of the
House a former Secretary of State for
culture that's Nadine Doris and Jacob re
smog their name in there and at least
three members of the House of Lords the
former and current members of the
government will have we have referred to
our privy councilors and that's an
additional responsibility in government
so an additional criticism there given
their recommendations as well go back on
the recommendations for me please and
then we can um just look at them again
there we go we recommend that the house
agree a resolution in the following
terms on your screen right now for you
ladies and gentlemen notes with approval
the special report from the committee of
privileges considers that where the
house has agreed to refer a matter
relating to individual conduct the
committee of privileges members of this
house should not impugn the Integrity of
that committee or its members or attempt
to Lobby or intimidate those members or
to encourage others to do so since such
Behavior undermines the proceedings of
the house and its itself capable of
being a contempt and it goes on to
considers its expedient that the House
of Lords is made aware of the special
report and this resolution so that the
house can take such actions as it deems
appropriate so they're saying there you
go this is what we think what do you
want to do about it well I think the
fact that they're saying it will be for
the house to consider what further
action if any is take and you'll
remember that when Boris Johnson was
felt the Privileges committee it was a
vote or a decision by the House of
Commons so what these what the committee
is effectively say in here K is that um
it's up to the other MPS to decide what
further action if any should be taken in
response to the report the committee has
just published but I think they're
basically saying that uh there's a
possibility that the house might set up
another privileges committee with a
different membership to now look at
these uh MPS named in the report to see
if they indeed now need sanctions and if
you sort of zoom out in the big picture
of this
um
it wasn't looking good for Boris Johnson
when he first gave evidence to the
Privileges committee earlier this year
the committee had said before he gave
evidence they thought it was likely that
he would be sanctioned that sanction was
massively Amplified by the conduct of
Boris Johnson himself around the report
coming out and I'm referring to his
public criticisms of the committee the
criticisms of the chair Harriet Harmon
saying she was not impartial calling it
a kangaroo court and then he had a
number of other supporters that piled in
on this and you know the report itself
said we were going to recommend a
sanction that would have triggered a a
recall petition that's when your
constituents can trigger a by-election
that's if you are suspended from the
house for over 10 days but in light of
what happened around uh the noise around
the report being published that that
sanction was massively Amplified as I
said to 90 days and now reflecting that
anger upset and also the concerns about
parliamentary
privilege and parliamentary procedures
and and integrity the committee are now
effectively saying to the House of
Commons look these people have
undermined the processes they've
undermined the committee uh they've
they've interfered with our work we
can't investigate them but we're now
asking you whether there should be
another investigation with another
privileges committee so the story that
uh we thought was was done in a way okay
with the with the vote uh just over a
week ago is still very much alive and
and for Rishi sunak I imagine that he
just wants this all to go away and it's
not going away okay so let's um just
wrap up then um Beth giving us the um
detail of this report but let me just uh
it looks as though it was social media
that did for them including the right
honorable Nadine Doris on Twitter she
said we also need to keep a close eye on
the careers of the conservative MPS who
sat on that committee do they suddenly
find themselves on chicken runs into
safe seats as best was saying Beth was
saying gongs perhaps uh were promises
made and on she goes uh Zach Goldsmith
again on Twitter check your tweets guys
before you press send in retweeting a
tweet calling the inquiry a Witch Hunt
and Kangaroo Court stated exactly this
there was only ever going to be one
outcome and the evidence was totally
irrelevant to it Mark Jenkins and when
the Witch Hunt has been forgotten future
Generations will look back in
astonishment Michael Fabric and serious
questions will need to be asked about
the manner in which the investigation
was conducted these were no jurists as
was apparent but the tone of the
examination the question of caliber
malice and Prejudice will need to be
answered now or by historians eight
people named in total will get more on
that for you here on Sky News